Walter is with us in Atlanta
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Walter
hey thanks for taking call days sure
what's up
alright basically some distance figure
out the best way to handle situation
which is newly married and my father
passed away last year I've never been
really into a credit card debt so zero
as far as that but with their heritage
money I didn't have my car and my house
so I took there's money paid off the car
paid off the house like the middle
America I'm actually living with my wife
in her house now renting out my house
and I have a hundred thousand dollars
left she has a lot of stupid little dead
and she's not interested in trying to
really take care of it so I'm trying to
go what should I do with the extra money
that I have less how much certain loan
does she have two hundred thousand good
lord
is she a doctor or a lawyer you know she
wouldn't be sat down with her finances
and basically she went into deferment
for a while and did the minimum payment
didn't know she was paying less than it
has her degree in communications a
master's yes in communications yeah how
long ago did she graduate 2013 five
years ago six years ago okay so this was
probably one hundred and fifty thousand
when she got out what he found something
like that yes she has no intention of
addressing the student loan I'm curious
landed on surveillance or plan they're
planning to die with it it almost seemed
that way she said basic she'll be the
payments and pay it off in 20 years or
that she's hoping to get her jobs it's
going to do some type of student loans
gives it some magical way it's going to
take care of herself how old are you -
I'm 46 41 okay
well there's two problems on the table
from the information you've given me
okay one is that and one is that you
guys are not working together and are
not in agreement on finances because one
of the top things as we study wealthy
people people who win at money okay one
of the top things we find in the data
points is that the husband and wife are
on the same page and they're in
agreement you all or not and so that
that's strike one for you're going to be
able to become wealthy strike two is
when we did this millionaire study that
we just finished that synchron's book
here's an interesting statistic when we
asked the question of the general public
do you think your destiny financially is
in your control sixty-two percent said
yes when we asked millionaires if they
think their destiny is in their control
and by the way ninety percent of them
did not inherit any money or enough to
become a millionaire some nine out of
ten of them were first-generation rich
when we asked them is your destiny in
control as opposed to sixty two percent
of the public said yes ninety-seven
percent of the millionaire said yes now
what that indicates Walter is hope that
says back there when they were broke
that they believed that if they planted
corn they would grow corn yes God has to
bring the rain yes God has to bring the
Sun but they believed that it that they
had if they control the controllables
that they could get out what I'm hearing
behind your wife's statements is a very
sad loss of hope she feels overwhelmed
and doesn't believe she can ever get out
that is a second data point in our
conversation that says you all are not
going to be able to build wealth we have
to fix those two things for you guys
Walter we have to help her have some
hope and you two have to get on the same
page or you're not going to win with
money you would be and it would be
unicorn if you did you'd be highly
unusual now what is your household
income sir
one fairy that's excellent and the
property that you paid off what is it
worth it's worth 222 excellent okay if I
could get the two of you on the same
page what I would do would be set about
I throw the hundred at her student loans
and I'd said about a two-year plan on
paying off the rest of them on beans and
rice rice and beans and I'd be debt-free
in two years or I would sell your
property and be debt-free in 20 minutes
of her student loans one of the two but
I would not keep those student loans
around like they're freakin pet yeah
it's just it's it's spiritually
emotionally disastrous and not to
mention financially and mathematically
because they indicate to her that she
feels trapped and the only way she's
going to get out is dumb luck mm-hm and
that tells me how hopeless she is and it
makes me feel sad for her art because
she's kind of got an attitude about it
she's kind of blowing it off but below
that attitude is this is this deep sense
of feeling trapped yes a lot so I'm sure
you don't buy yeah I'm sure and the good
news is she's got you the two of you can
do this together and you're not
overwhelmed I mean you could sell a
rental property and be gone tomorrow
yeah yeah but I wouldn't do that unless
we can agree to be on the same page
and unless we can as a result of that
caused us to hold our chin up and be
very hopeful about our future but right
now she's stuck in victim land and we
have to get her out of that land so I
wouldn't I wouldn't make any major moves
today until we can solve her hopeless
issue and until we can solve getting on
the same page issue as soon as we can
solve that I would either use the
hundred thousand and your income on
tight budget to become debt-free or I
would sell the rental property and
become debt-free
instantaneously one of the two but I'll
tell you something here's what I'm gonna
do I want to try to help with this
because I just my heart hurts for her
broken heart she's stuck and if I give
you Financial Peace University our nine
week class
for free can you get her to attend with
you do my best
she's not only but I would definitely
like I can get her to do it
yeah just as a favor as a favor to you
it's completely free I'm gonna make
anything I'm losing money on this okay
but here's here's the thing do not go
Walter without her because it's gonna
drive a wedge in your marriage because
you're gonna get more and more and more
excited about being debt-free and
building wealth and less and less and
less hopeless meanwhile she's gonna be
on the other side and it's gonna drive a
wedge between you and I don't want to
drive a wedge between you I want to help
you guys pull together and pull her up
out of this mud that she's in so hang on
I'm gonna give it to you but please
don't go to that class without her
because it'll make it worse
it's gonna make your young marriage your
young tender marriage worse and I don't
want to do that I would rather you just
find some other way to get on the same
page if that's what's going on here hang
on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get you
signed up for Financial Peace University
as my guest it includes the one-year
membership to financial peace which is
the whole thing online as well plus
every dollar plus is included Wow the
whole thing hundreds and hundreds of
dollars worth of stuff